philip rivers announcing his retirement
from the nfl after 17 seasons we thought
he was going to take some time
we thought the colts were going to take
some time i don't know if he got
the idea that maybe they weren't
interested or if he just decided on his
own
i'm stepping away with gas in the tank
but either way he's still got some gas
in the tank
he's moving on to his next challenge and
shireen look i think he's
one of the great quarterbacks of all
time the problem is
he gets lost in the shuffle of one of
the greatest generations of quarterbacks
we've ever seen
yeah two mvp votes throughout the course
of his career mike and those came in
2009 we always talk about russell wilson
not
get getting any mvp votes well we've
seen it with philip rivers because he
played in the eras
of peyton manning of drew brees
of tom brady and so he did get lost in
that shovel in fact mike i would argue
that he got lost in the shuffle of his
draft
class with ben roethlisberger
oh absolutely i mean roethlisberger's
got two super bowl wins
eli manning's got two super bowl wins
phillip rivers never
even got there and i understand it's a
team sport and i
understand that there's only so much one
person can do
but still of all the quarterbacks of the
past 20 years who we would regard as
great and
you consider philip rivers put together
enough yards to be fifth all time
passing touchdowns to be fifth all time
that's an impressive career
but when you don't make it to the super
bowl and you're never regarded as the
best in the sport in any of the 17 years
that you played
it just makes it hard to make the case
that your top 10 all-time
top 15 all time i don't know it look i
don't like throwing those numbers around
without actually making the list because
you know if you if you start taking all
the different guys that you say are top
10 and you stack them up you'll have 25
but
he's he's he has nothing to be ashamed
of for his career
but his career is even more incomplete
than the career of a guy like a fran
tarkin or dan marino because they at
least got to a super bowl i mean
philip rivers is basically a modern day
dan fouts a guy who never got to a super
bowl
same team generated a ton of yardage was
regarded as a great quarterback
but but never the best in the sport at
any given time
i had the comparison to dan phelps and
also to warren moon and if if
warren moon and dan fouts hadn't gotten
into the hall of fame i would be
questioning the hall of fame candidacy
of philip rivers
i do think because they they're in the
hall of fame
that philip rivers will one day be in
the hall of fame
i don't think phillip rivers is going to
be a first ballot hall of famer
and i am one of the people we argued
about this a little bit yesterday in the
meeting
i am one of the people that thinks that
there should be something special to
being a first ballot hall of famer i get
that the gold jacket isn't it more gold
it doesn't have real gold on it
if you're a first ballot hall of famer i
get all that but i still think there's a
difference
and i don't think that philip rivers is
a first ballot hall of famer
simply because i think it's more than
numbers you know this game a lot of
quarterbacks produce big numbers it's
got to be more than numbers it's got to
be playoff wins
it's got to be getting to super bowls
and he just frankly didn't do
that and and a lot of it was because he
didn't do that in the postseason when
you look at his postseason numbers
and his postseason record he didn't do
that in the postseason he didn't take
that next step i think it was great that
he played
with the torn acl in the afc
championship game when they didn't have
ladainian thomas with that entire game
either he was banged up and ended up
standing on the sideline for most that
game i was there for that game
but the fact is he didn't win that game
regardless of
how valiant it was that he played in
that game
he didn't get a win for his team in that
game mike and he made a point of it
in his statement that was released
announcing the retirement that
january 20 not only the feast day of
saint sebastian and philip rivers a
devout catholic saint sebastian regarded
as the patron saint of athletes it's
also the anniversary of the game that he
played without an acl in his knee he
pointed that out in his
statement and you know sheree when it
comes to first battle hall of famers
in my mind it is something that should
be reserved
for the guys like peyton manning who
have a 12 second debate
and no debate just a presentation as
mike chapel said we played the video
today
i'd like to just drop the laptop which
is the equivalent of dropping the mic
it's peyton manning
and david baker said any discussion no
discussion and that's that
that's to me what a first ballot hall of
famer should be
and if you require discussion questions
require debate you shouldn't be in on
the first ballot period
absolutely agree mike it's that person
that doesn't need the debate
there is no presentation hey even ray
lewis had a presentation it wasn't long
and there wasn't much discussion but
even he had a presentation had a
presentation a full presentation
so i i think it's that one guy and
they're rare i've been in that room now
since 2007 and there haven't been many
of them
but for those were you to stand up and
say ladies and gentlemen i
present whoever that quarterback is or
it's usually a quarterback but whatever
position it is and sit down that's all
that needs to be said we all know he's
going in
we all know peyton manning's going in
hey charles woodson even had a
presentation and i think he's getting
in this year but we still had a
presentation but there's only a handful
of those guys mike and i
with you we have put in way too many
first ballot guys over the past few
years who to me
didn't deserve that first ballot
designation
and i understand that there is a
psychology to the process there are
those five slots
maximum slash minimum guaranteed for
modern era candidates and you don't want
to waste them you want to make sure that
you put up five finalists who get the
votes and get in
because that keeps the flow that avoids
this backlog that you get to where
you've got plenty of guys who are worthy
that never get a fair shot
but there's there's other guys that can
get in other than people who are up
their first time there's
that backlog that's always there that's
what shocks me about the whole concept
of the first ballot hall of famer
who doesn't deserve it like a brian
urlacher all due respect
brian urlacher you shouldn't have been
in on the first ballot period
period sims said today when i don't know
if he said it on the air or off the air
and
if he set it off the air maybe it was
off the record i don't care he said
when they would play the bears when he
was in the nfl
they didn't gain plan for erlacker they
game plan for lance briggs
yeah and there's erlacker and i would
say jason taylor too to me
he's a hall of famer i just don't think
either one of those guys were first
ballot hall of famers and there's others
i mean i hate to point out those two
guys
and i did vote yes let's let's go there
i i did vote yes once they got to that
final five
but i do think there's a difference and
i just think it you you
have to be extra special to get that
first ballot and i don't think philip
rivers fits that
and i don't i'm not sure that eli
manning fits that even with two super
bowl wins here i am talking about philip
rivers not having super bowl wins
and eli manning does have that but i'm
not even sure he fits that bill i don't
know that he was
that truly special above everybody else
that you can just stand up and say
ladies and gentlemen i present eli
manning i don't think he fits that
either mike
and i don't fault you for voting yes on
a guy like erlacker when he's up on the
first ballot because once you're in the
final five
if you say no you're throwing him back
no
in the bowl with everyone else and
that's gonna hurt somebody else
and delay somebody else's entry to the
hall of fame
once you lock in the five i think it's
foolish to not vote yes
and clear them through the process and
have the next
so you don't have these angst ridden
decisions every year and
hey my theory on eli manning i don't
know if we've talked about this before
the fact that his name is manning
is getting him in on the first ballot
the fact that he's going to have peyton
pushing hard and you're going to hear
from peyton he's going to charm you and
he's going to charm all the other
voters i know it's going to happen write
it down it's four years away
there will be a charm offensive from
peyton manning to get eli in on the
first ballot
and eventually even the people who say
he shouldn't get in
will do it just to get peyton to shut
the hell up
well you know there's going to be that
push from the manning family there's no
question about that and they're going to
try to get him in on first ballot
it it will be interesting to me if he
does get on
in on first ballot sitting here right
now at this moment i would say i don't
think eli manning deserves first ballot
but
you always look at who's in that queue
mike and you talked about it if you vote
somebody down then then
that it just pushes everybody back and
you look at a guy like clay matthews
that plays so long for the browns and
this was his first time up for
discussion and it's also his last time
up for discussion this year
if he doesn't get in he goes into that
senior pool which is just an abyss and
now we only put in one senior every year
so you get lost in there so if a guy
like clay matthews doesn't get in this
year then he goes to that senior pools
and
out of there you look at a guy like john
lynch who's been on the list of 15
finalists since forever and 2014 and
2015
every guy every 15 all 15 guys from 2014
and 2015
are in the hall of fame aside from john
lynch so you know there's guys who've
been waiting a really long time to get
in and i just hate when you
bypass those guys for somebody that to
me doesn't deserve that first ballot
uh designation i have been very clear in
my position that i do not want to be
on the selection committee that is my
way of dealing with the reality that
they'll never invite me but beyond that
i can't do it i i don't have the
reservoir of tact and diplomacy
to make it through eight hours and 47
minutes without losing my cool at some
point and
if nothing else i am self aware but
there's one reason why
i'd be intrigued to have that power
because i'd love to be able to put off
peyton manning when he's trying to get
me on the phone
to talk me into voting for eli i'd be
like uh peyton
yeah you know i can't really talk to you
right now i'm a little bit busy can you
call me next tuesday let's say
4 55 p.m on the nose and if you don't
call that's on you not on me i kind of
like that
but other than that i'm not interested
in it but uh i i look forward to you
putting off peyton manning four years
from now when he's trying to get eli in
now four years from now presumably the
colts will have a quarterback who has
been their quarterback for more than one
season
they've gone from andrew luck to jacoby
brissette to philip rivers to who now
where do you think the coach should go
from here with philip rivers retired
well you're the first one that brought
it up mike but i think the the perfect
guy that fits what they do that's been
with frank wright before is carson wentz
i mean he makes a ton of sense but
it does sound like the eagles that's why
they parted ways with doug peterson
right because they wanted carson wentz
and he wanted jalen hurts
so if that's the case that's not going
to work out but i to me
if i'm the colts i absolutely approach
the eagles about what it would take to
get carson wentz
yeah i agree with you and maybe it's
just part of an elaborate ruse by the
eagles to create a trade market
for carson wentz and if so howie roseman
jeffrey ler today saying hey it's
working it's all fallen together
philip rivers retired maybe this will
work don't say anything about carson
what's let's
continue to create the idea that we want
carson wentz but i feel like they do
want to make it work with carson wentz
the other thing to keep in mind the cap
charges the cap accelerations it
it's a complicated year with the salary
cap likely to be i'm told in the range
of 180 million
delicate decisions to make when you've
got a franchise quarterback making big
money and you're looking at the prospect
of moving him off the roster there
aren't
many different categories where you can
explore if you're a team in need of a
quarterback you can draft one
duh you can sign a veteran free agent
who happens to be available
or you can trade for somebody that's
pretty much it and you know ryan
fitzpatrick's going to be available i
don't know that that's what the colts
want to do but if they're looking for
another band-aid see that's the question
are they looking for a band-aid or
looking for a bridge while they continue
to scour
draftable quarterbacks or do they want
someone that they know is going to be
the guy for five years and chris ballard
of the gm talked about it recently he
said there's a difference between
drafting a quarterback and drafting the
right quarterback i think it's a mistake
and we saw it with the titans the
jaguars and the vikings in the 2011
draft
jake locker blaine garrett christian
ponder teams that were desperate for
quarterbacks
they didn't have free agency that year
because of the lockout it came later
so let's just reach for a quarterback
when we shouldn't have taken those guys
and what happened
all three of them failed to live up to
the draft status
because they they were drafted at a spot
where they shouldn't have been
simply because the team got desperate i
think the colts are going to try to
avoid that shireen
yeah and you know mike they they were so
lucky because they went from peyton
manning to
andrew luck they had the one bad year in
there that
got them they tanked what a ha whatever
happened but they ended up with the
first round draft but for number one
overall pick and they ended up drafting
andrew luck and and
so luck locked into that franchise
quarterback and really didn't have to
search for one and now they're in this
great search
since luck retired of having to find one
and now this year you have the 21st
overall pick i mean
that's a tough spot to be in to think
you're going to get one of those top
guys that they're going to fall to you
and are you going to
mortgage your future so to speak to move
up to get one of those guys they're so
far down i just don't know if that's
going to happen
so i i look for them kind of probably to
have a bridge guy and maybe draft a
quarterback at some point that they can
think they can groom but uh
they're in a tough spot i think with
where they draft mike
and and what this free agency class of
quarterbacks looks like
maybe the trade is the route to go i
always say with ryan fitzpatrick that it
is easier to list the teams he hasn't
played for than the teams he has
i think the colts are in that
ever-shrinking group of teams
he has not played for so what the hell
you may as well
check another one off ryan fitzpatrick
if you want to play again i i don't
think that's in the long term obviously
it's not the long-term best interest of
the colts
but maybe maybe it's ryan fitzpatrick
plus somebody they get round two round
three somebody they fall in love with
during this
funky scouting process with no scouting
combine and they
they let that guy be groomed and
fitzpatrick doesn't have to worry about
getting benched
five six seven games in like what
happened to him this year in
miami hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights
from nbc sports